se puede esperar que este anuncio de al
sádr produzca un estallido violento en
irak e incluso hay temores de una
posible guerra civil cuál es la
importancia del líder chiíta dentro de
este país
bueno yo creo que mira que está en una
guerra civil de hace un par de años creo
que está haciendo en este momento
busquets al sadar que es un religioso
sin muchas creencias religiosas es decir
tu posición en lo que es una especie de
jerarquía religiosa no es la más alta es
decir tengo que dar es haber sido el
político más votado su partido ha sido
el partido más votado pero no tiene
llegue a tener una mayoría en el
parlamento valora un gobierno y lo que
el reciente es mucho es la influencia de
los iraníes dentro de la política iraquí
lo que está haciendo me parece que es
una amenaza el año pasado dijo lo mismo
que iba a renunciar a la política le
está diciendo que todos los partidos que
nacieron luego del orden estipulado
luego de la invasión estadounidense del
2003 deben renunciar porque no logran
estabilizar irak ahora es muy probable
que haya un estado de violencia porque
si recordamos poco en el pasado fuerzas
milicias pro iraníes milicias chiítas
proiraníes fueron incorporadas las
fuerzas de seguridad iraquíes y en este
momento
podemos decir que las fuerzas iraquíes
responden más aún a un dictamen a una
decisión de irán
siente que al sadar no siga sus órdenes
ciertamente y que vaya de manera muy
fuerte contra los los manifestantes pero
estadistas de una humanidad bueno y por
qué se produce este estancamiento que no
ha permitido la formación de un nuevo
gobierno que caminos le quedan a los
partidos políticos en el país
esto se produce porque un catalizador
que en un momento de la década pasada
estaba muy cerca de irán se ha alejado
de los dictámenes iraní recientes de
alguna manera la influencia de irán en
la política la política iraquí lo que
dice mosquete el sadar es en el a partir
del 2003 hasta por una década irak él
respondió a los dictámenes estados
unidos en la última década irak responde
a los dictámenes de irán ciertamente él
dice bueno nosotros tenemos que separar
nos dirán que irán no ve como una
especie de provincia y yo no quiero
formar un gobierno compartido que en
otras partes de ser presos son partidos
de todos los partidos pero iraníes
iraquíes se juntan tienen más diputados
que en un catalizador pero él dice yo
soy el partido más votado
yo no quiero de alguna manera hace un
gobierno con ellos a todo esto hay
también una lucha religiosa dentro de
irak muy interesante donde está el
ayatolá sistaní digamos con una posición
hay dos personas hay dos religiosos muy
fuertes en irak están las otras y tania
y que hacen al hajeri detrás están y
reside dentro de irak y reciente la
influencia iraní de la política iraquí
y que reside en irán y hoy ha dicho una
creación muy controvertida donde dice
que la política iraquí debe someterse a
los dictámenes de álica main que es el
líder máximo dirán lo que estamos viendo
acá es una lista no solamente política
sino de la lucha religiosa y esto lo que
nos indica que este conflicto incluso
los disturbios va a seguir por mucho
tiempo más bueno esto ya lo estaba
mencionando al saber ya había hecho
anuncios en el pasado de su retiro de la
vida política sin cumplirlos si esta vez
fuera real qué papel quedaría jugando
irán sería mucho más el poder que podría
tener al respecto y seguramente lo que
lo que yo creo personalmente hablando
con personas en el terreno es que la
gente los iraquíes es reciente en este
momento no quieren ser una provincia
iraní reciente mucho de la influencia y
danielle tenerle en terreno la semana
pasada se vio al día del agua
revolucionaria iraní y simplificando irá
como una especie de embajador y siendo
ex tratando de manejar los filos del
nuevo gobierno iraquí yo creo que esto
no vaya pero creo que al salar se va a
retirar de la política esto es una
especie de ultimátum para tratar de
parar en una especie de impass que no va
a resultar
aunque le diga que tienen que de alguna
manera
llegar a un algún tipo de un tipo de
acuerdo o bajar la virulencia de sus
manifestaciones no van a parar porque lo
que ven lo que se ve en el terreno es
que irán está manejando los hilos
directos